The "Romantische Strasse" is one of the best known "holiday roads" in Europe.
The 420-kilometer-long road starts at the River Main at Wurzburg...
...and leads to the town of Fussen.
While traveling many towns, you will gain a fantastic glimpse of Roman-built settlements,...
...medieval Germany and remainders of the time of the Renaissance.
You will really feel as if you are back in the middle ages.
If you decide to go there, it is useful to know that there are many ways to enjoy this road.
It is easy to book a bus tour,...
...and the good news is that some bus lines are free with a Eurail Pass.
For cyclists, there is an alternative route that uses side streets and bicycle paths.
A long distance trekking route is also available for the more agile tourists.
And one more thing!
You must not miss the most well-known castles: Schwangau,...
...Hohenschwanstein and Neuschwanstein.